hello there I'm John Oliver host of last
week tonight we are off this week for
Easter but we wanted to give you a
special message while we're away and to
do it in one of YouTube's most
entertaining forms I'm talking of course
of YouTube conspiracy videos science
fiction for people who don't understand
they're watching science fiction
whenever I see a YouTube conspiracy
video I'm overcome with jealousy
I mean first there's a wave of this guy
has to be kidding right but then
it's then his jealousy at the sheer
scale of imagination required to believe
that the Denver Airport was designed by
the Illuminati or that Katy Perry is
actually John Pinette Ramsey all grown
up both real theories by the way and
better than any joke I could ever device
in a million years now of course any
great internet conspiracy video needs
two key things one a wild claim that
something we take for granted is
actually the responsibility of robots
aliens or US presidents who are also
robots or aliens and two you need an eye
for incredibly specific detail and an
ability to make wild accusations with
complete confidence so that is why
tonight I'm going to make my own youtube
conspiracy video and take on a topic
that no one has had the guts to explain
I'm talking of course about the
conspiracy behind Cadbury cream eggs and
if you mean are you talking about why
they aren't available year-round then
they have already gotten to you turn
this off now you're a tool of the
establishment and you're too far gone to
wake up the rest of you open your eyes
open your eyes America the Cadbury Creme
Egg is a terrible candy that tastes like
mermaid percenter covered in candle wax
yet and yet every year these eggs show
up in January like newly signed gym
memberships or movie theaters full of
films that will never win Oscars but why
but why does this happen that's the
question and the reason is simple if you
just follow the money
the average Cadbury cream eggs sold in
the US waste 34 grams the same number of
streets in Miracle on 34th Street a
movie which takes place on Christmas
what's the most memorable Christmas gift
of all 5 golden rings
of course gold now York's largest supply
of gold is held by Germany Germany is
one of the sites where Freemasonry took
hold and where is the Cadbury
corporation based that's right the
United Kingdom which is only a quick and
affordable flight from guess where oh
yes Germany now now you might be asking
at this point John what does gold in
Germany have to do with candy in Britain
that question is a false flag I ask you
again I asked you again cui bono which
as we know is Latin for why is bono
everywhere all the time because that is
the connection here musicians here is
what they don't want you to know Cadbury
cream eggs were originally sold as fries
cream eggs oh why did they change their
name
what were they running from maybe their
true identity fry f:r why three letters
three like a triangle
now take your cream egg cut it in half
and put it in that triangle what does
that look like the Illuminati eye
Abaddon's pyramid I'll give you a second
to recover now you're clearly here can't
bring clean legs appear in our stores
for the financial benefits of Illuminati
elites such as jay-z Beyonce and Al
Sharpton now I have no idea if any of
that is true
in fact that's wrong I'm pretty sure
most of it is completely false but it
felt amazing to say and it almost made
sense and that is what YouTube
conspiracy videos are all about thank
you so much for watching we will be back
next Sunday on HBO with a new episode of
last week tonight until then go to bed
sheeple it's late open your eyes